well you may not realize but today is
the anniversary of a significant
milestone in our fight against
coronavirus one year ago pfizer released
its first data set showing positive news
it had a covid19 vaccine and it worked
since then plenty has changed two
billion doses have been distributed
worldwide and last week the company
released positive results for an
antiviral pill that can be taken orally
to treat covid patients well as pfizer
seeks uk approval for that one question
looms large is this the beginning of the
end of the pandemic as we know it well
joining me now
i'm very pleased to say is ben osborne
he's uk country manager of pfizer ben
very good morning to you obviously all
the uh talk now is of uh booster rollout
how do you assess progress right now
yeah good morning ian uh great to be
with you so i think the the nhs is doing
a a really sterling job of boosting our
population um
but i really would encourage all of
those who are eligible for a booster jab
to now come forward we know from the uh
you know the date and what we've heard
from nhs in recent days there's still a
way to go um so yeah we're making good
progress but uh people do need to come
forward
now as i mentioned in the introduction
now the hot topic right now is uh oral
uh antivirals when do you expect
progress on that here in the uk
yeah so as you uh as you said uh and we
announced the intro phase two phase
three data last week we're now working
at real pace uh with regulators around
the world and uh in particular in the uk
here with the with the mhra uh we expect
to be uh filing um in the in the near
future in the coming weeks uh and then i
would hope uh subject to their uh their
approval uh we may see um this uh this
medicine being available uh very early
in uh 2022.
yeah the uk government has obviously
pre-ordered a quarter of a million uh
such treatments uh those already being
manufactured regardless of of regulatory
approval
indeed we've been uh we've been working
at the uh the manufacturing side uh at
scale as we did with our vaccines for
for some time now uh so that we make
sure that we are ready for any
forthcoming regulatory approval both
here in the uk and further afield
now last month you announced that you're
going to start manufacturing your covid
vaccine in swindon i think thus far the
doses that we've received here in the uk
have been manufactured in in belgium why
have you done that
so this this is a global endeavor to
radio can't overcome the the global
pandemic and what we've sought to do
over the last 12 months really is to
scale up our manufacturing base
so that we're in a position to
manufacture and supply some 3 billion
doses this year
and in a position to uh
supply four billion doses in 2022 and we
recognized that there was an opportunity
to work with a partner thermofisher
scientific who had
an established facility uh in the in the
uk that we could then further kit out to
uh contribute to that global global
supply uh so we anticipate uh that uh we
will start seeing vaccine rolling off
those lines
again early in the first quarter of next
year
and put this into a global context for
me ben i mean how much of
the global production will swindon
account for roughly
yeah we've not announced and we don't
tend to announce any figures from our
any individual sites it really is uh a
sum of the parts uh to get to that three
billion uh doses uh but the swindon site
really is making a a very significant
contribution not to not just to uk
vaccine supply but the the global
footprint as uh as well
and obviously the wider fisa group is
working on new formulations of the
vaccine i mean roughly how much is being
spent on r d in this particular field
right now
so we've just announced in our earnings
last week that uh throughout this
financial year fizer will now be
investing 10.9 billion dollars across
our r d portfolio uh there's a
significant proportion that is going
into covid related uh science uh both in
terms of the the vaccine and the uh and
the antiviral uh and we expect to see
new formulations coming uh early in in
2022 which will make the vaccine for
instance easier to uh to use so removing
that dilution step uh and essentially
allowing the the nhs to simply draw up
the the vaccine
and vaccinate immediately without any of
the steps that we're taking right now
we keep hearing an awful lot about
skills shortages across the economy
right now ben are you seeing that in
pfizer uk at all
i mean we're seeing uh perhaps as you
would imagine uh real interest in uh in
future employees coming to work at
pfizer uh we have a a number of roles
they've been recruiting for recently
we've been inundated uh with scientists
and experts to come and work for our
organization but i do recognize the the
pressure across the the wider life
science sector and it's a a really
really important part for us all to
collaborate on and work collectively
with government so that we have the
skills necessary for for the future and
that needs to start at a very very early
age in the education system
obviously it's been a tumultuous 18
months what are the biggest learnings
from the pandemic being for you and how
can you apply them to future healthcare
challenges
yeah i i mean i think the uh there are
as follows the first is the power of the
public-private partnership um you know
we would not be where we are both here
in the uk with 46 million of our
population uh vaccinated if it wasn't
for for that that collaboration um that
has allowed us to not just develop uh
the the innovation and the science but
most importantly to scale that
innovation and to and to reach our
population so we really need to to
harness and recognize the value and the
importance of industrial expertise
working side by side with government
with the nhs and and others
i think we also need to recognize um the
approach that we've taken here really
has been around a collective mission a
collective purpose and that has shaped
cross-government policy and
cross-government uh investment and their
attitude approach to risk in particular
again another really important uh
learning to reflect on further for the
future
and finally i would would add this is
about uh end to end innovation so not
just focusing on the on the early
science but at every step of the way to
to nurture that science that innovation
and ultimately ensure that it reaches
our population
now obviously the week after next it's
world antibiotic awareness week you're
doing a lot around anti-microbial
resistance right now is that going to be
the next sort of big threat to to
humanity if you like
i i think so and and it's here right now
ian unfortunately um it's just a bit of
a sleeping giant relative perhaps to
what we can all see and feel with that
with covid in our our daily lives but we
do need to recognize uh that unless we
get on top of antimicrobial resistance
rapidly in the in the coming years uh
this will be as significant as covert
has been to our uh our health and our uh
and our economy um but there's much we
can do to uh to overcome that
all right ben orson good to talk to you
this morning thanks very much indeed for
joining me
thanks ian